fracking for shale gas in the uk a
controversial practice banned three
years ago because it caused earthquakes
but russia's invasion of ukraine is
driving an energy crisis and now the
british government has changed its mind
it is important that we use all
available sources of fuel within this
country it is something therefore that
we need to revisit and we need to
revisit the seismic limits to ensure
that shale gas extraction can be done in
an effective and efficient way
opposition parties are incredulous
for communities in every part of our
country today shows they can never trust
a word this government says again and he
has shown he is willing to break his
promises to support dangerous fringe
ideas that put the interests of fossil
fuel companies above that of the british
people
even the un's new climate chief is
watching carefully
we must phase out fossil fuels full stop
the
uh current uh energy crisis has forced
countries to backtrack
we are expecting this to be simply a
temporary
measure to get through the crisis
and then those countries will take the
necessary actions to get back on track
but in the meantime the fracking
industry is preparing to drill again
what is absolutely clear to us is that
in this energy crisis we have 50 years
worth of uk gas supply sitting under the
north of england
we really should be making an effort to
go and appraise that
officials also want to grant up to 100
new licenses for oil and gas in the
north sea
critics say you can't solve a fossil
fuel crisis by extracting more fossil
fuels
but the new government is set on doing
just that hannah thomas peter sky news